and do you think it's possible to do
like uh
like a tiny baby network that grows into
something that can do state of the art
and like even the simple data set like
mnist
and just like it uh just grows into a
you know gigantic monster that's the
world's greatest handwriting recognition
system
yeah there are approaches like that
esteban real and cochlear for instance
have worked on
evolving a smaller network and then
systematically expanding it to a larger
one
uh your elements are already there and
scaling it up will just give you more
power
so again evolution gives you that
starting point yes and then there's a
mechanism
that gives you the final result and a
very powerful approach
um but you know you could you could also
um simulate the actual growth process
and like i said before evolving a
starting point and then evolving it
uh or training the network there's not
that much work that's been done on that
yet
uh we need some kind of a simulated
simulation environment so the
interactions
uh at will the supervised environment
doesn't really
it's not as easily usable here
sorry the interaction between neural
networks yeah the neural networks that
you're creating
interacting the world uh and learning
from these um
sequences of interactions perhaps
communication with others
that's awesome we would like to get
there but uh just the task of simulating
something is at that level is very hard
it's very difficult i love the idea i
mean one of the
powerful things about evolution on earth
is the predators and prey emerged
and like there's just like there's
bigger fish and smaller fish
and it's fascinating to think that you
could have neural networks competing
against each other one yellow network
being able to destroy another one
there's like wars of neural networks
competing to solve
the mnist problem i don't know yeah yeah
oh totally yeah yeah yeah
and and we actually simulated also that
uh prayer the prey
and it was interesting what happened
there but bud padmini roger poland did
this
and um kay holcomb was a zoologist so we
had
again um
we had simulated hyenas simulated zebras
nice uh and initially you know the
hyenas just tried to hunt them and when
they actually stumbled
upon the zebra they ate it and were
happy
and and then the zebras learned to
escape
and the hyenas learned to team up and
actually two of them approached in
different directions
and now the zebras their next step they
uh
generated a behavior where they split in
different directions
just like actually gazelles do in in
when they are being hunted they confuse
the predator by going in different
directions
that emerged and then more hyenas joined
and and kind of circled them uh and
and then when they circled them they
could actually hurt the zebras together
and
and eat multiple uh zebras so there was
a
like an arms race of of predators
and prey and they gradually develop more
complex behaviors
some of which we actually do see in
nature uh and and this kind of
co-evolution um that's competitive
evolution it's a fascinating topic
because there's a promise or possibility
that you will discover something uh new
that you don't already know you didn't
build it in it came from this arms race
it's hard to keep the arms race going
it's hard to have reits enough
simulation
that that supports all of these complex
behaviors but at least for several steps
we've already seen it in in the spread
of gray scenario yeah
you